sons of anarchy ran from 2008 through
2014 and Charlie Hunnam remained an
audience favorite throughout the entire
run but what happened to him after the
last episode it seems like Hunnam hasn't
been quite the same since Sons of
Anarchy ended moving on from a role
after a beloved TV show ends is never
easy for an actor especially when
they've been playing that character for
several years for Hunnam saying goodbye
to Jax teller was difficult in fact the
way he describes the experience makes it
sound as though he went through a bit of
a grieving process Hannam was
overwhelmingly nostalgic for his time on
sons of anarchy and he admitted that he
would make up excuses to visit the set
and relive his days on the show
he told glamour I knew the security
guards and for a couple of days said oh
I forgot something so they'd let me onto
the set and I just walk around at night
because I wanted to be in that
environment and go through a personal
process of saying goodbye for six years
Hunnam knew that he had a secure
paycheck his Jax teller
but once the show finished its run he
was responsible for making big decisions
about his next career defining move and
he felt very intimidated by the process
Hunnam says that he struggles with
insecurity when it comes to maintaining
a career as an actor he told the talks
it's a tricky thing to quantify one's
career because in some ways I am in a
position where I want to be I'm getting
to work with good directors and tell
interesting stories but I always feel
like I have one failed movie away from
being unemployable
here we go right and only up from from
here on that punim isn't a fan of the
process of choosing roles and he doesn't
enjoy feeling the pressure to succeed at
the box office every time it's no secret
that Hunnam is well known for his good
looks but he's an actor at heart not a
model and he wants to earn respect and
attention for his talents he became
uncomfortable with the way some people
perceived him during his time on Sons of
Anarchy as someone who coasted to fame
on physical appearance alone when it
comes to how other people see him hon
I'm told in style I try not to think
about that too much because I'm just
attempting to shape my own perception of
myself and feel confident in my own
identity Hunnam then admitted there will
always be people who Sam is just to
quote pretty boy but despite the stigma
he still wants to face a challenge of
making each and every performance work
to the best of his ability when Hunnam
was young he lived in a rough
neighborhood so he always had to know
how to defend himself and when he signed
on to the film King Arthur legend of the
sword he had to go through it in
training regimen which included learning
Brazilian Jujitsu Hunnam ended up
getting super into the sport and he
started feeling the benefits of
consistent practice in fact he says that
jiu-jitsu changed his mindset
he told Men's Health it's not even as
much a physical benefit of training it's
the mental when you're training every
day in a combat discipline it just gives
you that eye of the tiger even after
shooting for King Arthur ended punim
stuck with jiu-jitsu and earned his blue
belt in 2018 hon of his new hobby seems
to have had a profound impact on him
after all he doesn't do anything halfway
and it's probably a good idea for
everyone to stay on his good side now
Hunnam doesn't think that Fame and
wealth are necessarily indicators of
success he says he actually prefers to
work on smaller projects with less
financial backing because he feels like
the director has more creative control
in that scenario as opposed to focusing
on accolades and high salaries he says
he just wants to challenge himself
create films that he's proud of and work
alongside directors who have interesting
ideas
he told Uproxx if I'm involved in a
project that I feel excited about and it
gives me a sense of purpose and it gives
me a sense of creative fulfillment that
is deep fulfillment to me and it evens
out the balance for me in my own journey
my success for me is about getting to
continue to work on things that make me
excited it seems like Hana has had a lot
to reflect on since Sons of Anarchy
ended and he's confident about the
direction he's going in now check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]